Katrina: 然后AI就可以说AI是从那个超市买的
Katrina: And the AI can say it was bought from the supermarket.
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Katrina: 我帮你找找吧
Katrina: Let me help you find it.
Alice:对这个就是这个这个
Alice: Yes, that's it, that's it.
Katrina: 我也不知道他在哪
Katrina: I don't know where it is either.
Alice:这个房间
Alice: This room.
Alice:他们就是租的时候这个的名字
Alice: They used this name when they rented it.
其他人：感觉已经被人拿走了
Others: It feels like someone already took it.
Katrina: 你上二楼
Katrina: Go to the second floor.
Alice:你喝我的水吧
Alice: Drink my water.
Katrina: 上二楼可能一共藏了20个
Katrina: There might be 20 hidden on the second floor.
Alice:这帮谁的
Alice: Whose is this for?
Alice:你就直接用我的吧
Alice: Just use mine.
Katrina: 那吉他是刚刚那哥们
Katrina: That guitar belongs to that guy just now.
其他人：人家弹的可好了吧
Others: He plays pretty well, right?
Katrina: 哎还行吧
Katrina: Eh, not bad.
Katrina: 他打架子鼓的
Katrina: He plays the drums.
Katrina: 这个二楼藏了多少个啊
Katrina: How many are hidden on the second floor?
Lucia: 2楼我们昨天真的藏了吗
Lucia: Did we really hide any on the second floor yesterday?
其他人：你藏了吗
Others: Did you hide any?
Katrina: 我没藏那二楼没有了
Katrina: I didn't hide any, there's none on the second floor.
其他人：那二楼没有了
Others: Then there's nothing on the second floor.
Katrina: 这个被藏了
Katrina: This one was hidden.
Katrina: 但是他现场藏的
Katrina: But it was hidden on-site.
Lucia: 那要不我们现场藏吧
Lucia: Then why don't we hide it on-site?
Katrina: 现场藏的是一楼
Katrina: The one hidden on-site is on the first floor.
Lucia: 请嘉宾先去一楼哈哈哈
Lucia: Please, guests, go to the first floor, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 我知道那但咱们那个贴纸呢
Katrina: I know that, but where's our sticker?
Lucia: 一楼刚才有个妹子好像找的差不多了
Lucia: A girl on the first floor seemed to have found almost everything.
Katrina: 也在一楼
Katrina: Also on the first floor.
Katrina: 刚才有个妹子好像找的差不多嗯
Katrina: A girl just now seemed to have found almost everything.
Lucia: 我感觉他找到咱们的那个
Lucia: I feel like she found our...
Lucia: 一包没拆开的那个
Lucia: The unopened package.
Katrina: OK我去拿一下
Katrina: Okay, I'll go get it.
Lucia: 然后他终结了游戏哈哈哈
Lucia: Then she ended the game, haha.
Katrina: 那那个贴纸在哪来着
Katrina: So where's that sticker again?
Katrina: 贴纸在哪来着
Katrina: Where's the sticker again?
Jake:那个谁东宇浩给我放哪 儿去了
Jake: Where did Dong Yuhao put it?
Lucia: 一整包了吗
Lucia: The whole package?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：啊我去我去
Others: Ah, I'll go, I'll go.
其他人：我带你下去
Others: I'll take you downstairs.
Katrina: 带金康的哦
Katrina: Take Jin Kang's, okay?
Katrina: 那你先下去然后他们藏一下
Katrina: Then you go downstairs first, and they'll hide it.
Katrina: 然后你来找吧
Katrina: Then you come and find it.
Katrina: 就这个这个女生
Katrina: Just this, this girl.
Katrina: 我们两男
Katrina: We two guys...
Katrina: 然后四个女生嘛
Katrina: And four girls, right?
Katrina: 还有两个女生在楼下
Katrina: There are two more girls downstairs.
Katrina: 一个是那个做蛋糕的
Katrina: One is the one making the cake.
Katrina: 还有一个就是那个
Katrina: And another one is...
Katrina: 反正戴眼镜的就是郑元畅
Katrina: Anyway, the one with glasses is Zheng Yuanchang.
Katrina: 然后其他就是邀请过来的朋友
Katrina: And the others are invited friends.
其他人：这两个
Others: These two.
Katrina: 情侣
Katrina: Couple.
Katrina: 他女朋友
Katrina: His girlfriend.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 我开空调靠二楼好热
Katrina: I'll turn on the air conditioner, it's so hot on the second floor.
Katrina: 遥控器呢
Katrina: Where's the remote?
Katrina: 贴纸在我这吗不是
Katrina: Is the sticker with me or not?
Katrina: 我的房间还没有收拾好
Katrina: My room is still a mess.
Katrina: 所以不能给你看
Katrina: So I can't show you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：老板他发我了吗
Others: Did the boss send it to me?
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
其他人：那个问卷不是
Others: That questionnaire, wasn't it...
Jake:PPT
Jake: PPT.
其他人：PPT
Others: PPT.
Jake:没了做吧
Jake: No more, just do it.
Lucia: 先去楼下收缴一个充电宝上来
Lucia: First, go downstairs and bring up a power bank.
其他人：可以JOPE给我
Others: Can JOPE give it to me?
Katrina: 你要不先下一楼我们藏一下
Katrina: How about you go downstairs first and we hide it?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Katrina: 哈哈藏吧
Katrina: Haha, let's hide it.
其他人：修硕你眼镜 好了吗
Others: Shure, are your glasses ready?
其他人：介是我忘删了顺手帮你带上来了
Others: I forgot to delete this, so I brought it for you.
Katrina: 来吧我们藏
Katrina: Come on, let's hide it.
Katrina: 藏个七八个
Katrina: Hide about seven or eight.
其他人：可以吧
Others: Is that okay?
Katrina: 你藏吗交给你了
Katrina: Will you hide it? It's up to you.
其他人：我知道我藏到现在还没有被找到所以
Others: I know, I've hidden it and no one has found it yet.
Katrina: 真假这么厉害
Katrina: Really? That's impressive.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
其他人：不会我下一个就没找到吧
Others: I won't be found next, right?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈唉
Katrina: Hahaha, oh well.
其他人：不可能找到的必不可能找到
Others: It's impossible to find, really impossible.
Katrina: 我给人家降低一点难度
Katrina: I'll make it a bit easier.
其他人：这怎么还降低难度
Others: How can you make it easier?
其他人：那我给他把难度拉满
Others: Then I'll make it as hard as possible.
Katrina: 害怕他很局促
Katrina: Afraid he'll be too nervous.
其他人：不要局促
Others: Don't be nervous.
Katrina: 天搞得像那是上presentation一样
Katrina: Gosh, it's like giving a presentation.
其他人：我觉得我找的地方真的是太厉害了
Others: I think the place I chose is really awesome.
其他人：干嘛我用的USB接口
Others: Why, I used the USB port.
其他人：真没有真没有
Others: Really not, really not.
其他人：哟还有个word
Others: Oh, there's also a Word document.
其他人：是的这不符合一下主题吗
Others: Yes, this doesn't fit the theme, right?
Katrina: 哈喽太恶了
Katrina: Hello, that's too nasty.
Jake:是吧太恶心了
Jake: Right? It's so disgusting.
Lucia: 可以我喜欢这个主题曲
Lucia: Okay, I like this theme song.
其他人：好我藏完了如果有一个是从我这儿找到的我就输
Other: Okay, I'm done hiding. If you find one from me, I lose.
Katrina: 你对我朋友好一点
Katrina: Be nicer to my friend.
Katrina: 哈哈我就叫他
Katrina: Haha, I'll call him.
Katrina: 欧了欧了
Katrina: All good, all good.
Katrina: 上来不你想喝啥不
Katrina: You coming up? What do you want to drink?
Katrina: 我给你找
Katrina: I'll find it for you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈这是一种game
Katrina: Hahaha, it's a kind of game.
Katrina: 你想喝什么不
Katrina: What do you want to drink?
Alice:嗯那倒不是
Alice: Hmm, not really.
Katrina: 我给你找找啊
Katrina: I'll find it for you.
Alice:大部分点外卖
Alice: Mostly order takeout.
Alice:然后有时候做火锅烧烤之类的
Alice: And sometimes cook hot pot or BBQ.
Alice:就录一下那个活动
Alice: Just record those activities.
Tasha: 今天结束
Tasha: Done for today.
Alice:嗯对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:然后明天就收尾
Alice: Then we'll wrap up tomorrow.
其他人：超级好每天还是
Other: Super good, still every day.
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
其他人：where is man
Other: Where is man?
其他人：：where is man
Katrina: where is man
Katrina: Where is man?
其他人：可以把最难的那个告诉你
Other: Can tell you the hardest one.
其他人：真的最难的那个
Other: Really the hardest one.
其他人：我藏在你装饰的门把手那里
Other: I hid it at your decorated doorknob.
Katrina: 我靠你对我朋友好点行吗
Katrina: Damn, be nicer to my friend, will you?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：whereisBUPT麦
Other: Where is BUPT Mike?
Katrina: BUPT麦没来
Katrina: BUPT Mike didn't come.
Katrina: 我草现在都有英文代号了
Katrina: Damn, we have English code names now.
Katrina: 我藏的还是比较那个的哟
Katrina: I hid it in a pretty tricky spot.
Katrina: 有多少个呀七八个
Katrina: How many? Seven or eight?
Katrina: 喝可乐不
Katrina: Want some Coke?
Katrina: 还是喝果汁
Katrina: Or some juice?
其他人：果汁
Other: Juice.
Katrina: 那要喝哪个
Katrina: Which one?
其他人：来这个吧
Other: This one.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
其他人：听过这歌吗
Other: Have you heard this song?
Katrina: 这个我没怎么听
Katrina: I haven't really listened to it.
Katrina: 刚才那个蓝蓝不是
Katrina: That blue one just now wasn't.
Katrina: 哈哈哈刚刚那个蓝
Katrina: Hahaha, that guy in the blue just now
Katrina: 蓝衣服t恤那个男生
Katrina: The guy in the blue T-shirt
Katrina: 清华本科大四
Katrina: Senior at Tsinghua University
Katrina: 我没接了
Katrina: I didn't get his contact
Katrina: 说不定你认识呢
Katrina: Maybe you know him
其他人：谁
Others: Who?
Katrina: 就刚刚那个
Katrina: The one just now
Katrina: 对就是那个蓝衣服的
Katrina: Yeah, the guy in the blue
Katrina: 你问你女朋友喝啥
Katrina: Ask your girlfriend what she wants to drink
Katrina: 别这么痴呆吗
Katrina: Don't be so dazed
Katrina: 你要睡了
Katrina: Are you going to sleep?
其他人：我很难想象你们这几天的作息有多恐怖
Others: I can't imagine how crazy your schedule has been these days
Shure: 来杯咖啡吧
Shure: Have a cup of coffee
Shure: 谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss
Katrina: 我考我每天3点钟睡都有人在这走动
Katrina: I swear, even when I sleep at 3 AM, there are people walking around
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 谢老板来杯咖啡吗
Shure: Thanks boss, want a cup of coffee?
Katrina: 然后每天11点钟起床
Katrina: And then wake up at 11 AM every day
Katrina: 耶找到一个
Katrina: Yay, found one
Shure: 好谢老板感冒了
Shure: Okay, the boss caught a cold
Katrina: 这是我藏的
Katrina: This is what I hid
Katrina: 交给谁呢
Katrina: Who should I give it to?
Katrina: 交给货币发起人吧
Katrina: Give it to the currency initiator
Katrina: 你保管货币吗
Katrina: Do you keep the currency?
Katrina: 修硕啊你保管吧
Katrina: Shure, you keep it
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 我保管了
Shure: I'll keep it
Katrina: 你不是货币发起人吗
Katrina: Aren't you the currency initiator?
Shure: 这这还有假币是吗
Shure: Are there counterfeit notes too?
Katrina: 这这这个也算吧
Katrina: Well, this could count too
Shure: 假币
Shure: Counterfeit notes
其他人：我们这通货是固定的好吗
Others: Our currency is fixed, okay?
其他人：一会儿别通货膨胀了
Others: Don't let there be inflation
其他人：不太好
Others: Not good
Katrina: 就是你可以掀我们的东西
Katrina: So you can lift our stuff
Katrina: 可能就被压在下
Katrina: It might be pressed down
其他人：没电了
Others: No power
其他人：这是吗这不是吧
Others: Is this it? This isn't it, right?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey
Katrina: 这是吗这好像不是吧
Katrina: Is this it? This doesn't seem to be it
Katrina: 这好像不是吧
Katrina: This doesn't seem to be it.
其他人：这是吧
Others: It is.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 这是这是
Shure: It is, it is.
Katrina: 试试可以试试哈哈
Katrina: Let's try, we can try, haha.
Shure: 完了开始已经有假币流入市场了
Shure: Oh no, counterfeit money has already started circulating in the market.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：你刚给我几个
Others: How many did you just give me?
Katrina: 给了你4个好像
Katrina: I think I gave you four.
Katrina: amazing完全完全看不出来
Katrina: Amazing, you totally can't tell.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
其他人：昨天藏摄像头后面那个呢
Others: What about the one hidden behind the camera yesterday?
Katrina: 一楼吗对
Katrina: On the first floor? Yeah.
其他人：我在一楼藏着都会被找到
Others: Even if I hide on the first floor, I'll still get found.
其他人：我发现我非常适合藏东西
Others: I found out I'm really good at hiding things.
其他人：这太难找了啊
Others: This is too hard to find.
其他人：你那个花瓶下的呢
Others: What about the one under the vase?
Katrina: 花瓶下的
Katrina: Under the vase.
Katrina: 一楼的吗
Katrina: On the first floor?
Katrina: 可能被他们女生找到了
Katrina: It might have been found by the girls.
Katrina: 上
Katrina: Go.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina: 够明显了哈哈
Katrina: It's obvious enough, haha.
Katrina: 二楼遥控器呢
Katrina: What about the remote on the second floor?
Katrina: 会不会在他们谁放
Katrina: Could it be where they put it?
其他人：这是你的麦克吗
Others: Is this your mic?
其他人：那个10分钟应该到了吧
Others: The 10 minutes should be up, right?
Katrina: 看见空调遥控器了吗
Katrina: Have you seen the air conditioner remote?
Katrina: 那在谁房间里
Katrina: Whose room is it in?
Katrina: 我房间里没有呀
Katrina: It's not in my room.
Shure: 你笑什么
Shure: Why are you laughing?
Shure: 我知道
Shure: I know.
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina: 可能会被在薇薇和露西亚的房间里
Katrina: It might be in Tasha and Lucia's room.
其他人：好油啊没人管管的吗
Others: This is so oily, is no one going to do anything?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Katrina: 薇薇那个空调遥控器有在你房间吗
Katrina: Tasha, is the air conditioner remote in your room?
Katrina: 不在也不在我房间哎
Katrina: It's not in my room either.
Katrina: 在你房间吗
Katrina: Is it in your room?
Katrina: 露西嗯
Katrina: Lucia, hmm?
Lucia: 呃应该没有
Lucia: Uh, there shouldn't be.
Lucia: 我从来没有见到
Lucia: I've never seen it.
Katrina: 哇你这样子玩的吗
Katrina: Wow, is this how you play?
Lucia: 哈哈因为我没有打火机
Lucia: Haha, because I don't have a lighter.
Katrina: 你问那个
Katrina: You should ask him.
Katrina: 谢谢谢冰烛借就行了
Katrina: Just borrow from Xie Bingzhu, it's fine.
Lucia: 他那个打火机好像棉芯有点用完了
Lucia: His lighter seems to have run out of wick.
Lucia: 然后就不太好着
Lucia: So it's hard to light.
Katrina: 啊啊
Katrina: Ah, I see.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上试了一下
Lucia: I tried it last night.
Katrina: 完了没空调遥控器啊
Katrina: Oh no, there's no AC remote.
Tasha: 拿不下来了已经
Tasha: It's stuck up there.
Katrina: 没有空调遥控器
Katrina: No AC remote.
Katrina: so hot哎
Katrina: So hot, ugh.
Katrina: 这有一个空调遥控器应该都能通用吧
Katrina: One AC remote should work for all, right?
Shure: 什么呀
Shure: What?
Katrina: 这这个
Katrina: This one.
Tasha: 太小了再挤大一点
Tasha: Too small, make it bigger.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Alright.
Alice:好热呀你热不热
Alice: It's so hot, are you hot?
其他人：正开空调
Others: The AC is on.
Katrina: 呵呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 拯救2楼
Katrina: Saving the second floor.
Katrina: 我以为你背吉他来了
Katrina: I thought you brought your guitar.
Katrina: 你去哪 儿玩儿
Katrina: Where are you going?
Katrina: 夹子在外面
Katrina: The clip is outside.
其他人：哦我明白
Others: Oh, I see.
其他人：厉害那我去试一试
Others: Impressive, let me try it.
Katrina: 那个他好像在弹你的吉他
Katrina: He's playing your guitar.
Katrina: 可以吗
Katrina: Is that okay?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Katrina: 他可以弹你的吉他吗
Katrina: Is it okay for him to play your guitar?
Shure: 他可以他可以
Shure: Yeah, it's fine.
Katrina: OK他在弹你的吉他
Katrina: Okay, he's playing your guitar.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm.
Shure: 我刚才拿拿出一瓶苏打水
Shure: I just got a bottle of soda.
Katrina: 几点了
Katrina: What time is it?
Shure: 哈 3:15我们
Shure: Haha, it's 3:15.
Katrina:  卧槽
Katrina: Woah.
Katrina: 时间过了一点
Katrina: Time really flew by.
Jake:哦人齐了吗
Jake: Oh, is everyone here?
Shure: 我刚才拿瓶苏打水放那
Shure: I just put a bottle of soda there.
Katrina: 但是人没齐是不是
Katrina: But not everyone is here, right?
Jake:那差谁点一下吧
Jake: Then who's missing? Check it.
Katrina: 呃LUCIA的朋友来了吗没来吧
Katrina: Uh, did Lucia's friend come? I don't think so.
Jake:点一下去每个人看看
Jake: Check each person.
Jake:露西亚露西亚在哪啊
Jake: Lucia, where's Lucia?
Katrina: 路夏在一楼烧那个东西
Katrina: Lucia is on the first floor cooking something.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Katrina: 我要拿个奶酪包
Katrina: I'm gonna grab a cheese bun.
Jake:我问问去问问去
Jake: I'll go ask, go ask.
Jake:你你去接哎
Jake: You, you go pick up, hey.
Katrina: 我刚刚接
Katrina: I just picked it up.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina: 找了半天我天哪
Katrina: I searched for a long time, oh my gosh.
Katrina: 天太随意了我们
Katrina: We're so casual.
其他人：BRITHDAY
Others: Birthday!
Katrina: 还有PPT吗
Katrina: Do we still have the PPT?
Shure: YES 咱们第一项不是PPT吗
Shure: Yes, isn't our first item the PPT?
Katrina: 第一项不是你去答题吗
Katrina: Isn't the first item you answering questions?
Shure: 人家PPT不就是你INTERDATION吗
Shure: Isn't the PPT your introduction?
Katrina: 我以为你INTRDATION
Katrina: I thought you were doing the introduction.
Katrina: 是他们INTRDATION呢
Katrina: I thought they were doing the introduction.
Shure: 啊不是不
Shure: No, no.
其他人：哎还有奶酪包
Others: Hey, there's still a cheese bun.
Katrina: 最后一个
Katrina: The last one.
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
其他人：开摆
Others: Let's start.
其他人： 是还是位置都不够
Others: There's not enough space.
Katrina: 那我们垫垫子坐地上行吗
Katrina: Can we sit on the floor with mats?
Katrina: 我刚刚还有个
Katrina: I just had...
其他人：可以坐在地上
Others: We can sit on the floor.
Katrina: 我想坐地上
Katrina: I want to sit on the floor.
Katrina: 第一天还是比较拘谨的
Katrina: The first day was more reserved.
Katrina: 所以我坐了凳子
Katrina: So I sat on a stool.
Katrina: 哈哈你
Katrina: Haha, you.
其他人：你可以一会选择坐在地上
Others: You can choose to sit on the floor later.
其他人：刚好两个靠背
Others: There are just two backrests.
Katrina: 今天就无所谓了
Katrina: It doesn't matter today.
Katrina: 几个嘉宾
Katrina: How many guests?
Katrina: 好像是6个人
Katrina: Seems like 6 people.
其他人：你老闲弃我干什么？
Others: Why are you always ignoring me?
Shure: 没有吗没有吗
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 那你是在
Shure: So you are...
Katrina: 唉我冰淇淋呢
Katrina: Hey, where's my ice cream?
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
其他人：我可以这么整 一个
Others: Can I do it this way?
Jake:我想一想我想一想这边可能
Jake: Let me think, let me think... maybe here...
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey...
Katrina: 还可以在这贴两个
Katrina: We can stick two more here.
Jake:就我们得都上去
Jake: We all need to go up.
Jake:那这个我们能上去搞吗
Jake: Can we do this up there?
Jake:要不这一头
Jake: How about this end...
Jake:这这这一波
Jake: This, this wave...
Jake:这波搞完我上去
Jake: After this wave, I'll go up.
Jake:好行上去就介绍一下然后开场
Jake: Alright, go up and introduce, then start the event.
Jake:呃到处每个房间走一走
Jake: Uh, walk around each room.
Katrina: 我靠收拾完了吗
Katrina: Damn, is it all cleaned up?
Jake:装饰完了吗
Jake: Is it all decorated?
Katrina: 没有那但是我已经收拾干净了
Katrina: No, but I've already cleaned it up.
Jake:那
Jake: Then...
Jake:好那就可以看是吧
Jake: Alright, we can check it out, right?
Tasha: 熟了还没有配料呢
Tasha: It's cooked, but there's no seasoning yet.
Katrina: 可以看
Katrina: We can check it out.
Jake:但那什么时候能出完全比完全平
Jake: But when can it be completely ready?
Tasha: 不行没有配料不好吃
Tasha: No, it won't taste good without seasoning.
Katrina: 完完完
Katrina: Done, done, done.
Jake:完全的屋子
Jake: Completely ready...
Katrina: 今天晚上就行啊
Katrina: Tonight will be fine.
Jake:完整状态
Jake: Fully complete.
Lucia: 呃对但是上去之前
Lucia: Uh, yeah, but before we go up...
Katrina: 因为我还有那个风铃跟一个贴墙上的
Katrina: Because I still have the wind chime and something to stick on the wall.
Lucia: 我会需要把那个东西再粘一下
Lucia: I need to stick that thing again.
Katrina: 没弄好因为今天早上弄压花去了
Katrina: Didn't get it done because I was pressing flowers this morning.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 不然他就会掉
Lucia: Or else it will fall.
Lucia: 你可以先寻别的房间
Lucia: You can check out other rooms first.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哈哈可以
Lucia: Haha, alright.
Katrina: 哦压花
Katrina: Oh, embossing.
Lucia: 对对对你们去别的房间的时候
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, when you guys went to the other room,
Lucia: 我就溜进去整理我的
Lucia: I sneaked in to organize my stuff.
Alice:确实驴打滚的亲戚
Alice: Yeah, definitely a relative of the donkey roll.
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hi.
Katrina: 我的打孔器呢
Katrina: Where's my hole punch?
Katrina: 弹什么呢
Katrina: What are you playing?
Katrina: 他说他说这个东西压不紧有点
Katrina: He said this thing doesn't press tight enough, it's a bit...
Katrina: 他说这个
Katrina: He said this...
Katrina: 这玩意老了
Katrina: This thing is old.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 就是那个嗯
Katrina: It's just that, um...
Katrina: 蓝色衣服那个清华本科那个男生
Katrina: That guy in the blue shirt, the Tsinghua undergrad.
Katrina: 他昨天晚上也谈这个普通朋友
Katrina: He was also talking about this with an ordinary friend last night.
Katrina: 原来发现都喜欢普通朋友
Katrina: Turns out everyone likes ordinary friends.
Katrina: 还有那个谁
Katrina: And then there's that...
Katrina: 还有那个不戴眼镜的那个
Katrina: And that guy who doesn't wear glasses.
Katrina: 一个志愿者他也弹
Katrina: 他俩昨天一起弹
Katrina: 的嗯
Katrina: Um...
Katrina: 弹琴怎么样
Katrina: How's the piano playing?
其他人：一般
Others: Just okay.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 我去找我打孔器去
Katrina: I'll go find my hole punch.
Shure: EGO Knight好吧
Shure: EGO Knight, okay.
Shure: 他是EGO house
Shure: He is EGO house.
Shure: 你是IGO Knight
Shure: You are IGO Knight.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
其他人：骑士
Others: Knight.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：GO house
Others: GO house.
Katrina: 无法只是普通朋友
Katrina: Can't just be ordinary friends.
Alice:你要吃哪个味
Alice: Which flavor do you want to eat?
Alice:刘天我都吃
Alice: Liu Tian, I'll eat them all.
Alice:不我要给你弄一个小的
Alice: No, I'll make you a small one.
Katrina: 感情
Katrina: Feelings...
Shure: 你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure: 不是你你是骑士
Shure: No, you, you're a knight.
Shure: 戴耳钉会怎么样吗
Shure: What happens if you wear earrings?
其他人：我戴的是耳钉吗
Others: Am I wearing earrings?
其他人：别他妈自我代入
Others: Don't f***ing insert yourself into this.
Shure: 你戴的是摇滚是吗哈哈
Shure: Are you wearing rock music? Haha.
Alice:我要整个鞋
Alice: I need the whole shoe.
其他人：整个啥
Others: The whole what?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Alice:爱心
Alice: Heart.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
其他人：  恶心啊快这样
Others: Gross, come on.
Alice:现在不会真能吃了吧
Alice: You really can't eat it now, right?
Shure: 了
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:真的这是熟的公主
Alice: Really, it's cooked, princess.
Shure: 怎么太多天看不着
Shure: Why, haven't seen you in so many days?
Shure: 没乐子看了是吗
Shure: No fun without watching, huh?
Shure: 把杜老喊来干嘛
Shure: Why call Du Lao here?
Lucia: 啊我小伙伴说他到花庄地铁站了
Lucia: Ah, my friend said he arrived at Huazhuang subway station.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:公主你的碗
Alice: Princess, your bowl.
Alice:赶紧吃了
Alice: Hurry up and eat.
Shure: 不就是回去见家长吗
Shure: Isn't it just going to meet the parents?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:公主请吃
Alice: Princess, please eat.
Alice:这是耻辱
Alice: This is humiliating.
其他人：喊姐妹哈哈哈
Others: Call your sister, hahaha.
其他人：轩是吧哈
Others: It's Xuan, right? Haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Hold on.
Lucia: 网又不太好了
Lucia: The internet is bad again.
其他人：喊妹妹吧
Others: Call your little sister.
Shure: 你非得要当一把大爷是吗
Shure: You really want to act like the boss, huh?
其他人：确实有点黏
Others: It's a bit sticky.
Lucia: 哈哈离炉子太近了
Lucia: Haha, too close to the stove.
Shure: 喊嫂子
Shure: Call sister-in-law.
Shure: 嫂子开门
Shure: Sister-in-law, open the door.
Shure: 我是我哥是吧
Shure: It's me, your brother, right?
Shure: 我们给他加油
Shure: Let's cheer him on.
Lucia: 转不出来了
Lucia: It's stuck.
Lucia: 我的手机
Lucia: My phone.
Alice:是不是水太少了
Alice: Is there not enough water?
Lucia: 看起来还有半屏
Lucia: Looks like there's still half a screen.
Alice:你点他不管用哦
Alice: If you click it, it won't work.
Alice:那个啥他没插电吗不是
Alice: Hey, isn't it plugged in?
Alice:你看那个那个那个那个
Alice: Look at that, that, that...
Alice:呃哪个不用啊
Alice: Uh, which one do we not need?
Tasha: 微波炉不用了
Tasha: We don't need the microwave.
其他人：这个好像不用
Others: This one seems unnecessary.
Alice:这个你别拔错了
Alice: Don't unplug the wrong one.
Lucia: 对有一点点
Lucia: Yeah, just a bit.
Alice:这个好像在
Alice: This one seems to be on.
Lucia: 没事做饭还是很容易被烫到的
Lucia: It's fine, but cooking still easily gets you burned.
Alice:正在通知你
Alice: It's notifying you.
Alice:要不你去其他地方把它挪走
Alice: How about you move it somewhere else?
其他人：二楼是不是还有水
Others: Is there still water on the second floor?
Tasha: 2楼那个是正常
Tasha: The second floor one is fine.
Alice:二楼也有
Alice: There's some on the second floor too.
Shure: 今天有多少个人
Shure: How many people are here today?
Lucia: 哈哈哈都可以
Lucia: Haha, it's all good.
Shure: 我算一算
Shure: Let me count.
Shure: 咱们都开始说9-11个人是吗
Shure: Are we saying 9-11 people?
Lucia: 等一下我擦擦手然后给他回一下
Lucia: Wait a sec, let me wipe my hands and then I'll reply to him.
Shure: 还是9-13个人对啊
Shure: Or is it 9-13 people, right?
Katrina: 你说所有吗
Katrina: Are you talking about everyone?
Lucia: 可以用这个纸
Lucia: You can use this paper.
Katrina: 不止不止
Katrina: Not just that, not just that.
Katrina: 我们都有 10个人
Katrina: We have 10 people.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 加6个嘉宾吧差不多
Katrina: Plus 6 guests, roughly.
Katrina: 呃我的打孔器呢
Katrina: Uh, where's my hole puncher?
Katrina: 又找不到
Katrina: Can't find it again.
Shure: 在外面呢
Shure: It's outside.
Shure: 你打红心
Shure: You hit the bullseye.
Katrina: 刚外面没看见呀
Katrina: I didn't see it outside just now.
Shure: 咱早上不在外面呢看着呢
Shure: Weren't we watching it outside this morning?
Katrina: 打打孔器哈哈哈
Katrina: Hole puncher, haha.
Katrina: 是我的打孔器呢
Katrina: Where's my hole puncher?
Katrina: 是不是没在外面
Katrina: Isn't it outside?
Katrina: 我刚找了一圈
Katrina: I just looked around.
Katrina: （歌声）我无法只是普通朋友
Katrina: (Singing) I can't just be an ordinary friend.
Katrina: （歌声）感情已那么深叫我怎么能放手
Katrina: (Singing) Our feelings are so deep, how can I let go?
Shure: 快把那天粉衣服那事换上哈哈哈
Shure: Quickly change into that pink outfit from that day, haha.
Katrina: 要上楼吗
Katrina: Should we go upstairs?
Shure: 快把妹妹还我
Shure: Quickly, give me my sister back.
Alice:干什么有肉
Alice: What are you doing with the meat?
Alice:有江浦还江浦了
Alice: There's Jiangpu, right?
Shure: 这么开放吗妈
Shure: So open-minded, mom.
Shure: 都允许找小的了
Shure: You even allow finding younger ones.
Lucia: 我是那个朱立文建材哈哈哈
Lucia: I am that Julie Wenjian company, haha.
Shure: 对4个人都好这样是吧
Shure: All four of us, right?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 还是不止4个妈妈
Shure: Or is it more than four, mom?
Lucia: 就是这个名字
Lucia: That's the name.
Lucia: 他比较长哈哈哈
Lucia: It's quite long, haha.
Alice:刘婷你愿意出多少钱买我的狗
Alice: Liu Ting, how much would you pay for my dog?
Katrina: 哼什么
Katrina: Huh, what?
其他人：什么你让我花钱
Others: What, you want me to spend money?
Alice:哈哈我的狗不值钱吗
Alice: Haha, isn't my dog worth anything?
Katrina: 怎么一股臭味
Katrina: Why does it smell so bad?
其他人：哎怎么敢吊针啊
Others: Hey, how dare you hang the drip?
其他人：居然投屏了
Others: You actually projected it.
Katrina: 行吗什么居然
Katrina: Really? What's surprising about it?
Katrina: 已经有视频了吗
Katrina: Is there already a video?
其他人：你的已经录
Others: Yours has already been recorded.
其他人：你的已经放完了
Others: Yours has already been played.
Jake:没关系你你先对
Jake: It's okay, you go first.
其他人：随机一会看
Others: Random, we'll watch in a bit.
Katrina: 我随便视频
Katrina: I'll just randomly record.
Jake:因为你也不知道拍成什么样
Jake: Because you don't know how it will turn out either.
Shure: 高级
Shure: Advanced.
Jake:我也
Jake: Me too.
Jake:我在昨天之前也不知道拍成什么样
Jake: I didn't know how it would turn out until yesterday.
其他人：所以这个OPTION到底是什么啊
Others: So what exactly is this OPTION?
Jake:拍卖
Jake: Auction.
Jake:拍卖竞价拍卖
Jake: Auction bidding, auction.
Katrina: 这歌好听
Katrina: This song is nice.
其他人：喜欢
Others: Like it.
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Jake:要帮忙吗
Jake: Need help?
Katrina: 这个怎么打孔器
Katrina: How do I use this puncher?
Katrina: 不应该感觉这薄薄的一层
Katrina: Shouldn't it go through this thin layer easily?
Katrina: 很容易一下按下去吗
Katrina: Shouldn't it press through easily?
Jake:就这么搞是吧
Jake: Just do it like this, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 长什么样
Katrina: What does it look like?
Katrina: 就一个孔
Katrina: Just a hole.
Katrina: 然后把这穿进去就行了
Katrina: Then you just thread this through.
Katrina: 孔子它应该是通的吗对
Katrina: The hole should be all the way through, right?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 你再打一个试试
Katrina: Try punching another one.
Jake:好再打一个
Jake: Okay, let's punch another one.
Jake:我感觉他刚是没对准
Jake: I think he didn't align it properly just now.
Katrina: 我感觉他双手没对准然后没有咔一下
Katrina: I think his hands weren't aligned properly, so it didn't click.
Jake:刚刚没有卡一下
Jake: It didn't click just now.
Jake:哎这个到位啊
Jake: Ah, this one is spot on.
Katrina: 那就是我劲太小
Jake:刚没对准
Jake: It wasn't aligned just now.
其他人：：喂喂
Others: Hello, hello.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 这留给自己吧
Katrina: Let's keep this one.
Katrina: 这做的一坨屎
Katrina: This one looks like crap.
其他人：声音好小
Others: The sound is too low.
Jake:能调能调
Jake: It can be adjusted.
其他人：TAISTIKE  TAISTIKE
Others: TAISTIKE, TAISTIKE.
Katrina: 你帮我把其他的都打了吧
Katrina: Can you help me punch the rest?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
其他人：所以你在干嘛 你放到他的电脑离上他电脑来放PPT吗
Others: So, what are you doing? Are you putting it on his computer to play the PPT?
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:你好
Jake: Hello.
其他人：今天晚上要不要来一首普通朋友
Others: Do you want to sing "Ordinary Friends" tonight?
Katrina: 我那朋友也会弹
Katrina: My friend can play it too.
Katrina: 你们一起吧
Katrina: You guys can play together.
其他人：好普通朋友
Others: Okay, "Ordinary Friends."
Katrina: （歌声）我们像是笑着扑火
Katrina: (Singing) We smile as we rush into the fire.
Katrina: （歌声）什么都不说
Katrina: (Singing) Without saying anything.
Katrina: （歌声）不说的是真
Katrina: (Singing) What we don't say is true.
Jake:你们谁想打孔
Jake: Who wants to punch a hole?
Katrina: 帮我打个孔包摁不动
Katrina: Help me punch a hole, I can't press it down.
Jake:打孔
Jake: Punch a hole.
Jake:来打个孔
Jake: Come on, punch a hole.
Jake:就在这打孔
Jake: Punch it here.
Katrina: 就握一下就行了
Katrina: Just press it once.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Katrina: 只是我的力气太小
Katrina: It's just that I'm not strong enough.
Jake:就这么样看啊
Jake: Just look at it like this.
Jake:然后在一个合适的位置
Jake: Then place it in a suitable position.
Katrina: 嗯按下去
Katrina: Hmm, press it down.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
其他人：哎呦我靠
Others: Oh my gosh!
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人：哇还挺好看的
Others: Wow, it looks pretty good.
Jake:就这么还好啥玩
Jake: So this is good, huh?
Katrina: 还行吧哈哈哈
Katrina: It's alright, haha.
其他人：什么情况
Others: What's going on?
其他人：所以你们每个人都有一组吗
Others: So, does everyone have a set?
Katrina: 没有就我做
Katrina: No, I'm the only one making it.
Katrina: 他们忙自己的东西
Katrina: They're busy with their own stuff.
Jake:他这个有点
Jake: This one is a bit...
Katrina: （歌声）于是你不停散落风不停失落
Katrina: (singing) So you keep falling, the wind keeps losing...
Katrina: 哈哈a
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：这么难打吗
Others: Is it really that hard to hit?
其他人：是不是不对啊
Others: Is it wrong?
Jake:没有没有没有这样这样这样
Jake: No, no, no, like this, like this.
Jake:就是他得是他得有一个支点
Jake: It needs a fulcrum.
Jake:你这样他比较好打
Jake: This way it's easier to hit.
Katrina: 他得有一个支点
Katrina: It needs a fulcrum.
其他人：给我一个支点我可以撬动地球
Others: Give me a fulcrum and I can move the earth.
其他人：确定是这种构造
Others: Are you sure this is the structure?
Katrina: 是的高中你们有打过那个就是讲义
Katrina: Yes, didn't you guys have this in high school? The handouts?
Katrina: 没也是用打孔器打然后搞一个穿
Katrina: We used a hole puncher and then inserted a ring.
Jake:这个可以这样可以
Jake: This can work, yes.
Katrina: 搞一个环可以穿着
Katrina: Insert a ring so it can hang.
Katrina: 没有哈哈哈哈
Katrina: No, haha.
Tasha: 好了没事
Tasha: It's alright now.
Katrina: 高中的时候没有笔记的习惯
Katrina: I didn't have a habit of taking notes in high school.
Jake:这个这个打孔器太离谱了
Jake: This hole puncher is ridiculous.
Jake:因为他这个很来我来我来我来
Jake: Because it's very... I'll do it, I'll do it.
Katrina: 你看贴贴这上也好看
Katrina: See, it looks good when you stick it here too.
其他人：对对好看了好看了
Others: Yes, yes, it looks good.
Jake:这个对啊
Jake: This, yes.
Jake:就是他他这个握的很窄
Jake: It's just that the grip is very narrow.
Jake:就是你只能这么
Jake: You can only hold it like this.
Jake:他要大一点的话就很爽
Jake: If it were bigger, it would be great.
Katrina: 受力分析
Katrina: Force analysis.
Jake:就就就各位手太大了
Jake: It's just that everyone's hands are too big.
Jake:就是这么回事
Jake: That's how it is.
其他人：那我手
Others: Then my hand...
Jake:可能还不够小
Jake: Maybe it's still not small enough.
Jake:使不上劲
Jake: Can't use enough force.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 我也感觉使不上劲
Katrina: I also feel like I can't use enough force.
Katrina: 这个真的
Katrina: This is really...
其他人：哦不是他他你你这样你这样
Others: Oh no, not him, you do it like this, like this.
其他人：这样就不好使这个地方
Others: This won't work here.
其他人：所以对就是就是
Others: So yes, exactly...
其他人：其实你稍微摁摁个印然后他就
Others: Actually, if you just press it a little, then it will...
其他人：就你拿这个指头这个位置啊
Others: You use this finger, this position.
其他人：我记得当时初中还刚学过一篇课文
Others: I remember in middle school, we just learned an article.
其他人：叫陈小手
Others: It was called "Chen Xiaoshou".
其他人：就是接生的那个
Others: It was about the midwife.
其他人：接生的医生叫陈小手
Others: The midwife doctor was called Chen Xiaoshou.
Jake:你已经ONESHOP的学会这件事件
Jake: You've already learned this event in one shot.
其他人：妈的确实 我现在感觉
Others: Damn, indeed. I feel...
Katrina: 好了吗人跟机器没有什么区别
Katrina: Alright, there's no difference between humans and machines.
其他人：人跟机器没有什么区别
Others: There's no difference between humans and machines.
其他人：尤其每次当我速成的时候
Others: Especially every time I learn quickly.
其他人：我就觉得我就像那个蓝莓的魔鬼一样
Others: I feel like I'm that blueberry devil.
其他人：学什么会什么
Others: I learn anything immediately.
其他人：会什么
Others: Anything.
其他人：没喂的就不会
Others: If I don't feed it, it won't work.
Katrina: 打孔穿进去就行了
Katrina: Just drill a hole and put it through.
Alice:这呢
Alice: Here it is.
其他人：这花你是从哪拿来的
Others: Where did you get this flower?
Katrina: 就是我们种的那个花
Katrina: It's the flower we grew.
Katrina: 然后把它压干了种的
Katrina: Then we pressed it and dried it.
Katrina: 就我第一天不就买了花吗
Katrina: Didn't I buy flowers on the first day?
Katrina: 然后再分
Katrina: Then we divided them.
其他人：那这个叫抽空气吗
Others: Is this called vacuum sealing?
Katrina: 不用吧哈哈
Katrina: No need for that, haha.
其他人：那怎么那怎么不蔫呢
Others: Then why doesn't it wither?
Katrina: 就是我已经把它压成这样压干水分了
Katrina: Because I pressed it like this to dry out the moisture.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Katrina: （歌声） 很久以前人们都许诺
Katrina: (singing) Long ago, people promised...
Jake:很难
Jake: It's hard.
Jake:很反人类的设计
Jake: It's such an inhumane design.
其他人：很难
Others: It's hard.
其他人：确实
Others: Indeed.
Jake:就是应该是这么哑
Jake: It should be this dumb.
其他人：能发给我一个狐狸链接吗
Others: Can you send me a fox link?
Katrina: 啊狐狸
Katrina: Ah, a fox.
Katrina: 我昨天还没找到
Katrina: I couldn't find it yesterday.
Jake:我来我来我来
Jake: I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll do it.
其他人：这样的给我一个
Others: Give me one like that.
Jake:给我一个
Jake: Give me one.
Katrina: 哈哈哈也行只要他没那个破相机
Katrina: Haha, sure, as long as it doesn't have that broken camera.
Jake:送一个
Jake: Send one.
其他人：咱俩那天在互相机的操作然后转
Others: That day, we were operating each other's cameras and then spinning.
Jake:行吧哦转是吧
Jake: Okay, oh, spinning, right?
其他人：然后你就是弄完以后转
Others: And then you spin after you're done.
其他人：但是转他还是不太好
Others: But spinning it isn't very good.
其他人：但是我这个是不是已经没有
Others: But mine is already not...
Jake:自信呢自信呢
Jake: Confident, confident.
其他人： 哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
其他人：coffee哎你别你别把它花出来花呀
Others: Coffee, hey, don't, don't spend it, spend it.
Jake:我们只旋转我们只旋转
Jake: We only spin, we only spin.
Katrina: 这不能应该应该不能这样
Katrina: This shouldn't be, shouldn't be like this.
Katrina: 这样的话我抽不着哇
Katrina: If it's like this, I can't draw it.
Jake:哎不行不行
Jake: Oh no, no.
Jake:这个有点破坏破坏的有点大这个
Jake: This is a bit too destructive.
其他人：这个啊你这你这已经装不进去了是吗
Others: This, ah, it can't be installed anymore, right?
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
其他人：记不住可
Others: Can't remember.
Katrina: 可以可以
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Katrina: 只能有一个孔刚刚那个烂了是吗
Katrina: There can only be one hole, the previous one is broken, right?
Jake:你们这么压是有用的吗
Jake: Is it useful for you to press it like this?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
其他人：烂了就不太好
Others: If it's broken, it's not good.
其他人：这个是吗
Others: This one, right?
Katrina: 嗯到时候给他粘一下
Katrina: Hmm, just stick it later.
Katrina: 就是这能卖的出去吗
Katrina: Can this be sold?
其他人：哈哈也要卖啊
Others: Haha, you're going to sell it?
Katrina: 就是拍卖啊大
Katrina: It's an auction, right?
Katrina: 家不是每个人都做的东西吗
Katrina: Isn't everyone making these things?
Katrina: 他们卖小狗
Katrina: They sell puppies.
其他人：卖小狗哦
Others: Selling puppies, huh?
其他人：那个小狗是卖的
Others: That puppy is for sale.
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Exactly, exactly.
Katrina: 总归要找点环保东西
Katrina: We need to find some eco-friendly stuff.
Katrina: 就是拿一狗币换一狗币
Katrina: It's like trading one dogecoin for another.
Jake:哎这么不值钱哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, it's that worthless? Hahaha.
其他人：EVERYBADY HAS EGO COIN
Others: EVERYBODY HAS EGO COIN.
Jake:搞不懂一点
Jake: I don't get it.
Jake:你来吧
Jake: You do it.
Jake:我放弃了
Jake: I give up.
Jake:我我不行
Jake: I can't do it.
Katrina: （歌声）一无所有钱
Katrina: (singing) No money at all.
其他人：我来我是通才
Others: I'll do it, I'm versatile.
Katrina: （歌声）至少你可以说
Katrina: (singing) At least you can say.
Katrina: （歌声）是的我觉得最寂寞
Katrina: (singing) Yes, I feel the loneliest.
Katrina: （歌声）失去了我
Katrina: (singing) Lost me.
Katrina: （歌声）失去的都是人生
Katrina: (singing) Losing is part of life.
Katrina: （歌声）我们之
Katrina: (singing) Between us.
Katrina: （歌声）所有所有却至少你可以说是的
Katrina: (singing) All, all, at least you can say yes.
Katrina: （歌声）活着的最寂寞你
Katrina: (singing) The loneliest while alive.
其他人：所以三幅画你可以当grade一下
Others: So, you can grade these three paintings.
其他人：只要有个孔就可以了
Others: As long as there's a hole, it's fine.
Katrina: 恩恩
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
其他人：哎看着这个用的挺挺挺衬手的
Others: Hey, this one feels quite handy.
其他人：为什么使劲的时候这么菜呢
Others: Why is it so weak when you use force?
Jake:他就是他就是不成熟
Jake: He's just not mature.
Katrina: 是不是他打纸会好一点
Katrina: Maybe he'll be better with paper.
Jake:他就是
Jake: He's just...
Katrina: 打这种塑料就可以
Katrina: He can handle plastic.
Katrina: 你试一下
Katrina: Give it a try.
Katrina: 搞一张试搞一个这个
Katrina: Try one, try this.
Katrina: 试一下看看
Katrina: Give it a shot.
Katrina: 是这个这个东西的问题
Katrina: It's this thing's problem.
Katrina: 随便打对对
Katrina: Just hit it, yeah.
Katrina: 这随便打
Katrina: Just hit it.
Katrina: 嗯随便打
Katrina: Yeah, just hit it.
其他人：这样打不过打不过
Others: Can't hit it like that.
其他人：我现在一把就退啊
Others: I'll back off after this shot.
其他人：哦这随便打
Others: Oh, just hit it.
Katrina: 哦那就是塑料不太好弄
Katrina: Oh, so the plastic is hard to handle.
其他人：塑料不太好弄
Others: The plastic is hard to handle.
其他人：那个纸要打
Others: The paper needs to be punched.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
其他人：用这个钉子来
Others: Use this nail.
其他人：对啊这不是我5分钟之前就发现了
Others: Yeah, I noticed that like 5 minutes ago.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哦
Katrina: Hahaha, oh.
其他人：就你稍微你稍微
Others: Just a little, a little.
其他人：这不是咱们5分钟之前
Others: Didn't we notice this 5 minutes ago?
Jake:好那我们现在就是
Jake: Alright, so now we...
Jake:operation了一下发现还是东西最好吃
Jake: After some operation, we found out it's still the best thing to eat.
其他人：不对称了一下
Others: Symmetrically.
其他人：发现还是这个东西最好用
Others: We found this is still the best to use.
Jake:来你打过来给他们
Jake: Come on, punch it and give it to them.
其他人：来你打过来给他
Others: Come on, punch it and give it to him.
其他人：对对他是个不均匀
Others: Yeah, it's uneven.
其他人：受力不均匀
Others: The force is uneven.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahaha.
其他人：哈哈他把你这个器件给卸了
Others: Haha, he took your component apart.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
其他人：我想试一下亮度会不会更好
Others: I want to see if the brightness gets better.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Katrina: 呀我的那个东西又掉了
Katrina: Ah, my thing fell again.
Katrina: （歌声）在疲倦的汹涌中将一无所有全
Katrina: (singing) In the midst of exhaustion, I will have nothing left.
Katrina: 这是送给
Katrina: This is for...
Katrina: 这可以当书签
Katrina: This can be a bookmark.
Katrina: 不人家说书签
Katrina: No, they said it's a bookmark.
其他人： 好确实塑料不太好改
Others: Yeah, plastic is really hard to modify.
其他人：我霸气我感觉不太好看
Others: I feel like it's not very good-looking.
其他人：他觉得你打比人打透了才好
Others: He thinks it's better if you punch all the way through.
其他人：这压根就没穿
Others: This didn't go through at all.
其他人：这个你可以一会补救一下
Others: You can fix this later.
其他人：这是刚刚破的
Others: This just broke.
其他人：这个
Others: This.
Katrina: 啥时候开始啊
Katrina: When are we starting?
其他人：什么时候开始
Others: When are we starting?
Katrina: 催一下
Katrina: Hurry up.
Katrina: 有点
Katrina: A bit...
Katrina: 他们那甜点没做好
Katrina: Their dessert isn't ready yet.
其他人：我在施法
Other: I'm casting a spell.
Katrina: 在帮我打孔
Katrina is helping me drill holes.
其他人：一会儿我马上EGO HOUSE变成EGO NICE我要施下法。
Other: Soon I'll turn EGO HOUSE into EGO NICE, I'm going to cast a spell.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 我靠我还做了蛮多嘞
Katrina: Wow, I actually did quite a bit.
其他人：好又给你搞成一个
Other: Okay, I'll make another one for you.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Other:
其他人：   就将就着用
Other: Just make do with it.
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Katrina: 没破就行
Katrina: As long as it's not broken.
其他人：草我怎么明天又要去上班了
Other: Damn, I have to go to work again tomorrow.
其他人：我真的好难过呀我草
Other: I'm really bummed out, damn.
其他人：上海呀上海呀
Other: Shanghai, Shanghai.
其他人：那不给子伟干活还是很快
Other: Isn't it quick to work without Ziwei?
其他人：那个东西是那个东西
Other: That thing is that thing.
其他人：他不另外人很多
Other: He's not with many others.
其他人：不啊就是这个东西的包装又不在我
Other: No, it's just that the packaging of this thing is not with me.
其他人：他们要用GT4V给包TV又打标
Other: They need to use GT4V for packaging and label it.
其他人：这东西包装又在前又不在我
Other: This packaging isn't with me.
其他人：他们推进速度很快
Other: They are moving really fast.
其他人：他们都是老手了
Other: They're all pros.
其他人：方舟潘亮他们这些人train的diffusion
Other: Fangzhou, Pan Liang, these people trained the diffusion.
其他人：那都是老手啊
Other: They're all pros.
其他人：：他们现在还写套路
Other: They're still writing routines.
其他人：：潘亮去洗身吗
Other: Did Pan Liang go to wash up?
其他人：方舟不联系
Other: Fangzhou isn't in touch.
其他人：潘亮是啥
Other: What is Pan Liang?
其他人：潘亮是啥呀
其他人：方舟潘亮现在不是那个airwag的青年
Other: Fangzhou and Pan Liang are now young people at Airwag.
其他人：研究科学
Other: Doing research.
其他人：他应该相当于入职
Other: He should be equivalent to joining.
其他人：在哪还有朝夕
Other: Where there's still morning and night.
Alice:这个好吗
Alice: Is this good?
其他人：还有那个这一届跟我一起入学的PHD
Other: And that PhD who enrolled with me this year.
其他人：超冷
Other: So cold.
其他人：哇
Other: Wow.
Katrina: 我去催一下他们
Katrina: 我啊
Katrina: Me.
其他人：有没有压花压坏的那种
Katrina: 你来你来
Katrina: You come, you come.
Katrina: 哈哈我就问问他们啥时候开始
Katrina: Haha, I'll just ask them when they start.
Katrina: 啥时候开始
Katrina: When do we start?
Jake:露西亚有一个同学
Jake: Lucia has a classmate.
其他人：露西亚是去接了吗
Others: Did Lucia go to pick them up?
Jake:哦那很好
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Jake:就接一下就到就好了
Jake: Just pick them up and bring them over.
Jake:让他们坐好吧
Jake: Have them sit down.
Jake:要不好不对
Jake: Otherwise, it's not right.
Katrina: 呃呃坐好啊
Katrina: Uh, uh, sit down.
Jake:坐到2楼坐好
Jake: Sit on the second floor.
其他人：是长这样吗
Others: Is it like this?
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
其他人：太慢了什么手机啊
Others: It's too slow, what kind of phone is that?
其他人：换了
Others: Change it.
其他人：你怎么天天天天在这里让人家换手机
Others: Why are you always asking people to change their phones?
Shure: 正
Shure: Exactly.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 上上上
Katrina: Let's go, let's go.
Katrina: 我们已经比预计的晚了二十几分钟
Katrina: We're already twenty minutes behind schedule.
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it.
Katrina: 赶紧上去
Katrina: Hurry up and go.
Katrina: 特别欠你看
Katrina: Especially, look at you.
Katrina: 上
Katrina: Go.
其他人：点个外卖
Others: Order some takeout.
Katrina: 点什么外卖
Katrina: What takeout?
Katrina: 不是晚饭吃披萨吗
Katrina: Aren't we having pizza for dinner?
其他人：天天吃披萨
Others: Pizza every day.
Katrina: 每天吃点预制菜
Katrina: Pre-made meals every day.
Katrina: 一辈子就这么过了
Katrina: Living life like this forever.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 是的活着的罪
Katrina: Yes, it's a sin to live.
Tasha: 就是冬天那种光秃秃的树干啊
Tasha: It's like those bare trees in winter.
Tasha: 有树枝
Tasha: With branches.
Katrina: 健康说上去坐着
Katrina: Healthy, go sit down.
Katrina: 他们既然录下的朋友就开始上去不
Katrina: Since they've recorded their friends, let's go upstairs.
Alice:你先上去吧
Alice: You go up first.
Lucia: 对就是这个
Lucia: Yes, that's it.
Alice:刘婷带着我上楼找个地坐那
Alice: Liu Ting will take me upstairs to find a place to sit.
Lucia: 是金康你
Lucia: It's Jinkang, you.
Lucia: 来解释一下要不
Lucia: Explain it, will you?
Katrina: 就上楼坐着
Katrina: Just go upstairs and sit.
Katrina: 不用带啥
Katrina: You don't need to bring anything.
Katrina: 什么都不用带
Katrina: Don't bring anything at all.
Katrina: 脑子都不用带哈哈
Katrina: You don't even need to bring your brain, haha.
Tasha: 太大了
Tasha: It's too big.
Alice:结过边还很大吗
Alice: Even after trimming the edges, it's still big?
Tasha: 嗯我不想要就是边
Tasha: Yeah, I don't want just the edges.
Alice:有剪刀没啊
Alice: Do we have scissors?
Katrina: 没剪刀在外面我给你拿
Katrina: No scissors here, they're outside. I'll get them for you.
Alice:直接剪吧
Alice: Just cut it directly.
Alice:那个太不好用了
Alice: That one is too difficult to use.
Katrina: （歌声）你可以是
Katrina: (singing) You can be...
Katrina: （歌声）着的活着的罪
Katrina: (singing) ...alive, alive with guilt...
Katrina: 这个吗
Katrina: Is this it?
Katrina: 这是他们的货币
Katrina: This is their currency.
Katrina: 拿着不
Katrina: Do you want it?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:刘婷顾头不顾腚
Alice: Liu Ting only cares about the head and not the tail.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Alice:啊你给他拿上去
Alice: Ah, you take it up to him.
Alice:顺便骂他一下
Alice: And scold him while you're at it.
Alice:说呢固头不固定
Alice: Tell him, only cares about the head and not the tail.
Alice:这个小不小
Alice: Is this small?
Alice:就是这个边的
Alice: It's just the edge.
Alice:哦满足
Alice: Oh, satisfying.
Katrina: 哈喽哈喽
Katrina: Hello, hello.
Jake:哈喽哈喽哈喽
Jake: Hello, hello, hello.
Jake:那就齐了上楼吧
Jake: Alright, that's everything, let's go upstairs.
Katrina: 上楼吧速速开始
Katrina: Let's go upstairs and start quickly.
Katrina: 迟到43分钟哈哈哈
Katrina: We're 43 minutes late, haha.
Katrina: （歌声）你是不是想我
Katrina: (singing) Are you thinking of me...
其他人：来给你来开场
Others: Come on, start the show.
Jake:来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
其他人：开场来展示一下
Others: Start the show and show us something.
Jake:来请
Jake: Please.
Shure: 你要从那儿你要从那一进来
Shure: You need to come in from there.
Katrina: 你进来我给你喊出来
Katrina: You come in, and I'll announce you.
Jake:啊好
Jake: Ah, okay.
Jake:你当DJ是吧
Jake: You're going to be the DJ, right?
Jake:等大家等人齐了吧好吧
Jake: Let's wait until everyone is here, alright?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈彩排
Katrina: Hahahaha rehearsal
其他人：先预热一下
Others: Let's warm up first
Jake:排练一遍
Jake: Let's practice once
其他人：杨靖康
Others: Yang Jingkang
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:耶哈哈
Jake: Yeah, haha
Katrina: 真受不了
Katrina: I really can't take it
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Katrina: 那我把东西
Katrina: Then I'll take the stuff
Jake:机长是晚了
Jake: The captain is late
其他人：求人是不是
Others: Are you asking for help?
Jake:耶
Jake: Yeah
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:可以
Jake: Got it
Jake:这就是学术榜的
Jake: This is the academic list
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Alice:but梅西亚和蓝莓
Alice: But Messia and Blueberry
Jake:请进
Jake: Please come in
Jake:欢迎欢迎啊
Jake: Welcome, welcome
其他人：马斯特
Others: Master
Shure: 少爷嘛
Shure: Young master
Shure: 满三好你看
Shure: Man San, look
Shure: 找找地儿坐
Shure: Find a place to sit
Katrina: 你坐吧坐吧坐吧
Katrina: Just sit, sit, sit
Katrina: 你们先坐吧
Katrina: You guys sit first
Shure: 请坐请坐
Shure: Please sit, please sit
Shure: 要不你坐我旁边
Shure: How about you sit next to me
Shure: 就坐那个
Shure: Just sit there
Katrina: 你们嘉宾坐前面吧
Katrina: You guests sit in the front
Shure: 席地而坐
Shure: Sit on the floor
Katrina: 就是邀请的好朋友刚好有6个
Katrina: It's just that the invited friends are exactly six
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Katrina: 你们就坐吧
Katrina: You guys just sit
Shure: 把MC的位置让回给我
Shure: Give me back the MC position
Katrina: 不是坐凳子哈哈哈
Katrina: Not sitting on chairs, hahaha
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey
Lucia: 哎你们
Lucia: Hey, you guys
Shure: ladies and gentlemen
Shure: Ladies and gentlemen
Lucia: 没事没事加冰座
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, add ice seats
Lucia: 哈哈你们俩可以坐一块
Lucia: Haha, you two can sit together
其他人：OK
Others: OK
Shure: 你突然不想跟我坐一块是吗哈哈
Shure: You suddenly don't want to sit with me, huh? Haha
Lucia: 反正我一会应该还要下去弄那个甜点
Lucia: Anyway, I should go downstairs to make the dessert soon.
Katrina: 你不坐吗
Katrina: Aren't you sitting?
Katrina: 我不坐这不是嘉宾坐的吗
Katrina: I'm not sitting here. Isn't this the guest's seat?
其他人：哦这嘉宾坐的
Others: Oh, this is the guest's seat.
Shure: 给我来个宝儿呗
Shure: Can you get me a power bank?
Katrina: 啥呀
Katrina: What?
Shure: 充电宝
Shure: A power bank.
Katrina: 哦哦哦sorry
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, sorry.
Katrina: 一点默契都没有
Katrina: No coordination at all.
其他人：靖康拿个充电宝上来
Others: Jingkang, bring a power bank up here.
其他人：靖康有英文名字吗没有
Others: Does Jingkang have an English name? No.
Shure: 他叫JK yes
Shure: He's called JK, yes.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 下下一秒就感觉又
Shure: In the next second, I feel like...
Jake:什么充电宝
Jake: What power bank?
Lucia: 久违的久违的相机
Lucia: The long-lost camera.
Jake:那就拿一点呗
Jake: Just bring some then.
Katrina: 哦我也需要充电宝
Katrina: Oh, I need a power bank too.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 让我现
Katrina: Let me see...
Lucia: 我以为你是在南京工作
Lucia: I thought you worked in Nanjing.
Lucia: 所以你是在北京工作
Lucia: So, you work in Beijing?
Katrina: 我现
Katrina: I see...
Lucia: 哎我
Lucia: Oh, I...
Lucia: 那我可能是某一次刷到你定位在南京
Lucia: Then I might have seen your location in Nanjing once.
Katrina: 思考
Katrina: Thinking...
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something like that.
Katrina: 还有充电宝吗
Katrina: Any more power banks?
Jake:有有有
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:有一些要小心使用的充电宝
Jake: There are some power banks you need to use carefully.
Katrina: 什么意思
Katrina: What do you mean?
Jake:就是它得
Jake: It's just that...
Jake:它在一直在闪它才是充电
Jake: It needs to keep flashing to charge.
Jake:所以要比较小心
Jake: So be careful.
Jake:就不像这么明显
Jake: It's not that obvious.
Katrina: 上吧
Katrina: Got it.
Katrina: 开始了得
Katrina: Let's start.
Jake:好那我们这边就算可以开始还需要
Jake: Okay, then we can start from here, but we still need...
Katrina: （歌声）是的活着的最寂寞
Katrina: (singing) Yes, the most lonely thing in life...
Lucia: 没事人家还没打开呢哈哈
Lucia: It's okay, they haven't opened it yet, haha.
Katrina: 看我们的充电线
Katrina: Look at our charging cable.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 因为我们前几天刚好买了同款茶
Lucia: Because we happened to buy the same tea a few days ago.
Lucia: 然后对大家以为还有先放到这
Lucia: So everyone thought there was more and put it here first.
Shure: 没有不
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 一点不像
Shure: Not at all.
Katrina: 这是谁做
Katrina: Who made this?
Lucia: 啥这个上面吗
Lucia: What, this thing on top?
其他人：egoboss哈哈
Others: egoboss, haha.
Lucia: EGOBOSS
Lucia: EGOBOSS.
Jake:对所以我们嘿嘿
Jake: Yes, so we, haha...
Katrina: 谁是主持人啊
Katrina: Who's the host?
Katrina: 你啊
Katrina: You are.
Jake:三三点50
Jake: Three, three fifty.
Jake:因为下面的甜点还在准备
Jake: Because the dessert downstairs is still being prepared.
Jake:所以还有点奶油要挤
Jake: So there's still some cream to be added.
其他人：需要我去Siri停一下吗
Others: Do you need me to stop Siri for a bit?
Jake:嗯对可以加完速加个5分钟的速我们
Jake:就开始4点吧
Jake: We'll start at 4 o'clock.
Jake:4点 4点
Jake: 4 o'clock, 4 o'clock.
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 哈哈 4点开始
Katrina: Haha, start at 4 o'clock.
Jake:就这么4点吧
Jake: Let's just start at 4 o'clock.
Jake:好 4点开始
Jake: Okay, start at 4 o'clock.
Katrina: 我们原定的3点开始
Katrina: We originally planned to start at 3 o'clock.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:那你们开个场吧
Jake: Then you guys kick it off.
Shure: 五十
Shure: Fifty.
Jake:你要不就不是你
Jake: If you don't, it's not you.
Jake:你的music开场啊
Jake: Your music kickoff, huh?
Katrina: 你你的music开场了
Katrina: Your music kickoff.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Katrina: 唱首歌吧修硕哈哈哈
Katrina: Sing a song, Shure, haha.
Shure: 普通朋友
Shure: Just friends.
Shure: 给大家给大家放放点歌吧好吧
Shure: Let me play some songs for everyone, okay?
其他人：不行听你唱
Others: No, we want to hear you sing.
Shure: 听我唱听我唱什么听我唱
Shure: Listen to me sing? What do you want to hear me sing?
Shure: 给大家放放点
Shure: Let me play some music for you all.
Shure: 大家平时喜欢听什么呀
Shure: What do you usually like to listen to?
Shure: 下一位嘉宾先来什么可以
Shure: What should our next guest perform first?
其他人：可以可以
Others: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 哈哈哈他也听普通朋友的
Katrina: Haha, he listens to "Ordinary Friends" too.
Katrina: 两票普通朋友呢
Katrina: Two votes for "Ordinary Friends."
Shure: 啊那后面那位哥哥
Shure: Ah, how about that guy back there?
其他人：挺好
Others: Sounds good.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 两两两位同学
Shure: Two, two, two classmates.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 放吧放别问了
Katrina: Just play it already, stop asking.
Shure: 下面这首歌曲是所有嘉宾点的
Shure: The next song is requested by all the guests.
Shure: 普通朋友
Shure: "Ordinary Friends."
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
其他人：哎我唱这么好
Others: Wow, I sing so well.
Shure: 那你看原唱懂吗
Shure: Do you understand the original singer?
其他人：那个是不是酒啊
Others: Is that alcohol?
Shure: 这是苏拉水苏拉水
Shure: This is Sula water, Sula water.
Katrina: 苏打
Katrina: Soda.
其他人：这是一楼啊好多喝的
Others: There's so much to drink on the first floor.
Shure: 哦对
Shure: Oh, right.
Jake:暖起来
Jake: Warm it up.
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Jake:暖场专业暖场
Jake: Warm up the place professionally.
Shure: 是不是大家这个场子不够不够
Shure: 不够热那要不把空调调高两度吧
Shure: It's not warm enough. How about we turn up the air conditioning by two degrees?
其他人：好
Others: Sure.
Katrina: 我不要哈哈哈
Katrina: I don't want to, haha.
Shure: 那个大家大家口渴什么的
Shure: Is everyone thirsty or something?
Shure: 冰箱里有
Shure: There's stuff in the fridge.
Shure: 有橙汁桃汁
Shure: There's orange juice, peach juice.
Shure: 还有元气森林ad钙奶
Shure: Also Genki Forest AD milk.
Shure: 还有酒还有咖啡
Shure: There's also alcohol and coffee.
Katrina: 买的养乐多呢
Katrina: What about the Yakult we bought?
Shure: 大家想喝什么
Shure: What do you want to drink?
Katrina: 你有啥想喝的吗
Katrina: Do you want anything to drink?
Shure: 可以在我这里order一下点一下
Shure: You can order it from me.
Shure: 这就不用好了
Shure: No need to order anymore.
Shure: 重新再来一遍
Shure: Let's do it again.
Shure: （歌声）我无法只是普通
Shure: (singing) I can't be just ordinary.
Shure: 大家知道今天是什么日子吗
Shure: Do you all know what day it is today?
Shure: 大家知道
Shure: Do you all know
Shure: 今天自己参加这个活动的主题
Shure: what the theme of today's event is?
Shure: 叫什么吗
Shure: Do you know?
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: Do you know?
Shure: yes today is
Shure: Yes, today is...
其他人：叫WELCOME DAY
Others: It's called WELCOME DAY.
Shure: earth day
Shure: Earth Day.
Shure: 大家知道世界地球日是大概干什么
Shure: Do you all know what Earth Day is about?
Shure: 的一个日子吗
Shure: What kind of day it is?
其他人：4月22号
Others: April 22nd.
其他人：对吗你是
Others: Right? You are...
Shure: 大家知道大概是干什么
Shure: Do you all know what it's about?
Shure: 有没有踊跃举手回答的
Shure: Anyone eager to raise their hand and answer?
Shure: 就是我们有小红花作为奖励的
Shure: We have little red flowers as rewards.
其他人：草不会猜对了吧
Others: Grass, did you guess correctly?
Shure: 怎么了怎么了
Shure: What? What?
其他人：猜对了就不好了
Others: If you guessed right, it's not good.
Shure: 再问你一遍
Shure: Let me ask you again.
Shure: 你喜欢流沙
Shure: Do you like quicksand?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈有品
Katrina: Hahaha, that's cool.
Katrina: 版本哪个版本哈
Katrina: Which version, huh?
Shure: 我送你两个字沙雕
Shure: I'll give you two words: silly goose.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 我不敢
Katrina: I'm scared.
Katrina: 我的转移要破的
Katrina: My transition is about to break.
其他人：水喝多了要上厕所
Others: Drink too much water, need to go to the bathroom.
Katrina: 无法直视
Katrina: Can't look directly.
Katrina: 你看多帅
Katrina: Look how handsome.
Shure: 给大家先放一点
Shure: Let's play a bit first.
Shure: 这个跟今天日子相关的这种
Shure: Something related to today's theme.
Shure: 来自迈克尔杰克逊的Heal the world
Shure: Michael Jackson's "Heal the World".
Katrina: 你看你看
Katrina: Look, look.
Katrina: 是不是刚讲他就马上刚讲AI like
Katrina: Didn't he just say it, AI like?
Shure: 你干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
其他人：这个Safari
Others: This Safari...
其他人：怎么把这个东西默认为谷歌搜索先
Others: How to set this as the default Google search first?
Shure: 怎么
Shure: How...
其他人：你先装个咕咕咕噜
Others: You first install a Gugu Gulu
Shure: 好久没见乐子了是吗
Shure: Haven't seen Lezi for a long time, right?
其他人：不不不我就用你先装个谷歌谷歌
Others: No no no, I just want you to install Google Google first
其他人：告诉你要不要把Safari换了
Others: Told you to switch from Safari
其他人：然后你就换了就可以
Others: Then you switch it and it works
Katrina: 我去找我的冰淇淋
Katrina: I'm going to find my ice cream
Alice:在这
Alice: Here it is
Katrina: 哇还有麦旋风吗
Katrina: Wow, is there still a McFlurry?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Alice:你的麦旋风
Alice: Your McFlurry
Jake:昨晚的麦旋风
Jake: Last night's McFlurry
Katrina: 现在要拿上去吗
Katrina: Should I take it upstairs now?
Katrina: 还是等会他们下来吃
Katrina: Or wait for them to come down and eat?
Tasha: 剪很很很窄的就行了
Tasha: Just cut it very very narrow
Tasha: 剪跟他
Tasha: Cut it like him
Katrina: 还有3分钟
Katrina: 3 minutes left
Alice:还有3分钟啥
Alice: 3 minutes for what?
Katrina: 4点开始
Katrina: Starts at 4
Tasha: 剪刀剪一下就行
Tasha: Just cut it with scissors
Jake:我4点开始剪一下剪刀了
Jake: I'll start cutting with scissors at 4
Alice:在那在那
Alice: There, there
Jake:有点
Jake: A bit
Alice:这个不好使
Alice: This one's not working well
Alice:反正无妨
Alice: Anyway, it doesn't matter
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Oh
Katrina: 就是我的冰淇淋
Katrina: It's just my ice cream
Katrina: 那天采购的时候夹带的
Katrina: Bought it last time we shopped
Katrina: 私 货哈哈对
Katrina: Sneakily, haha, yes
Katrina: 我们出去玩的吧
Katrina: Let's go out and have fun
Katrina: 哦哦哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh oh hahaha
Katrina: 下面还有两盒麦旋风呢
Katrina: There are still two boxes of McFlurry downstairs
Katrina: 昨天点多了还放冰箱里
Katrina: Ordered too many yesterday, still in the fridge
Jake:剪一下剪一下
Jake: Cut it, cut it
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah
Katrina: 多少钱一个
Katrina: How much is one?
Katrina: 那个我也没好意思吃
Katrina: Didn't dare to eat it
其他人：麦当劳昨天剩的那
Others: Leftover from McDonald's yesterday
其他人：那个汉堡
Others: That burger
Katrina: 太奢侈了
Katrina: Too luxurious
Katrina: 昨天麦当劳点了500块钱
Katrina: Ordered 500 yuan worth of McDonald's yesterday
其他人：那么多人差不多
Others: That's about right with so many people.
Katrina: 昨天麦当劳点了500多块钱
Katrina: Yesterday, we ordered over 500 yuan from McDonald's.
Katrina: 朵儿朵儿
Katrina: Dorr, Dorr.
Katrina: 我们平常一顿米村拌饭也才200多
Katrina: Usually, a meal from Micun Banfan only costs around 200 yuan.
其他人：米村拌饭便宜
Others: Micun Banfan is cheap.
Katrina:  对麦当劳居然点了500多
Katrina: But we actually ordered over 500 yuan from McDonald's.
其他人：还有勺我想吃
Others: There's still a spoon, I want to eat.
其他人：没勺了只有这一个
Others: There's no spoon left, just this one.
Katrina: 要不给你拿个麦旋风上来
Katrina: Should I get you a McFlurry?
Katrina: 要吗我就给你拿一个随便吃
Katrina: Do you want it? I'll get one for you, eat whatever you want.
Katrina: 这两个都是新的吧
Katrina: These two are new, right?
Alice:哪个
Alice: Which one?
Katrina: 麦旋风
Katrina: The McFlurry.
Alice:对有一个杨老板的
Alice: Yes, one of them is Jake's.
Katrina: 两个都是他的吗
Katrina: Are both of them his?
Alice:有一个是
Alice: One of them is.
Alice:另外一个不知道
Alice: Not sure about the other one.
Katrina: 他有预定哪一个吗
Katrina: Did he reserve any of them?
Katrina: 应该都是新的吧
Katrina: They should both be new, right?
Alice:没有嗯
Alice: No, he didn't.
Katrina: 我拿我朋友吃
Katrina: I'll take it for my friend to eat.
Alice:因为昨天这是画的
Alice: Because this one was ordered yesterday.
Katrina: 拿给我朋友吃
Katrina: I'll take it for my friend to eat.
Jake:你是客人是吧
Jake: You're a guest, right?
其他人：麦旋风哈哈
Others: McFlurry, haha.
Katrina: 楼下有就拿着吃
Katrina: If it's downstairs, just take it and eat.
其他人：刚买的麦旋风
Others: Just bought the McFlurry.
Katrina: 不是昨天晚上的
Katrina: It's not from last night.